pour pierre laurin journaliste et
écrivain spécialiste de la russie et de
l'ukraine au delà du sommet en format
normandie les négociations tourneront
autour du rôle de l'otan et de son
extension
il faut à l'otan il lui faut un ennemi
pour continuer d'exister et aujourd'hui
la russie est l'ennemi idéale
avant le pacte atlantique
l'organisation du traité de l'atlantique
nord s'étaient créés contre l'union
soviétique depuis 30 ans l'union
soviétique n'existe plus mais
l'alliance athlètes atlantique continue
d'exister et à cette alliance atlantique
il lui faut toujours un ennemi pour
continuer à rassembler autour d'elle les
pays qui la composent et sans
déperdition donc
la russie fait figure de l'idée de delmi
idéal ça peut simplement ça ne peut pas
durer parce que d'une part la russie en
a marre et d'autre part les occidentaux
voient très bien où se situe la limite
de cette position la limite de cette
position c'est évidemment le risque de
guerre et c'est un risque que personne
n'est disposé à prendre aujourd'hui